what's interesting about you is the
concept of ownership in the real world
you view
as kind of a lack of freedom you were
saying yeah i i think
i value
freedom
to make big
leaps into the unknown is exceptionally
important so i also value love and
monogamy and relationships all those
kinds of things right those put a limit
on for a lot of people those put a limit
on freedom right i don't see it that way
so like i think people use that as an
excuse in the same way house ownership
people often use as an excuse
to get complacent to to to limit
themselves so i i don't think how i
don't think ownership in itself is a
limit on your freedom but people get
comfortable they get soft it becomes a
limitation because i want to be able to
tomorrow
say you know i'm going to start a
company and i'm not going to do it in
austin i'm going to do it in kansas city
i'm going to do it in san francisco and
move just
uh walk away yeah cool guys don't look
back at explosions just walk away just
walk away and that that
something about me i mean i don't want
to generalize but for me i probably
won't do that but the freedom to do that
allows you to think big
to to uh take leaps into uh the unknown
in a way that materializes like the best
version of yourself
i i mean i i fully
agree
as a person who bought a house well i i
did i did buy a house i think that
part of what i
like is problems
yes problems are essential for my
business
um what's your business exactly uh
uh it's a great question um
i think it it it's um
you know in in his very simplest form
it's um
making people happy
right that's like the simplest way to
say it and if there are no problems
there's never going to be a reason to
make anyone happy that's why utopians
hate comedy because they think you can
create a world in which there will be no
pain so if there is no pain there's no
reason to alleviate that pain through
comedy but i'm someone who realizes that
no matter how great you make the world
you're gonna have pain you're gonna have
problems so one of the reasons that i
kind of
like entanglements
problems things like that is because i
see a lot of opportunities in them
to
um
you know release that
valve of pressure
comedically so you lean into the chaos
because from the chaos comes a lot of
problems and then you can
understand the human condition by
analyzing i think that's part of it i
also think i i have to do things
to know what they are
and part of my job is to hopefully make
those things funny
so by by owning a house
i've i've owned houses that i mean i own
one house that i lost i'm
very open about that during the mortgage
crisis right so i went through that
and now i bought a house very
responsibly but when you buy a house
very responsibly it's still very much
you know
a um weight
it's a weight
on you you feel that weight you know
and
but there's value i think to weighing
yourself down sometimes yes
because then you understand what other
people are going through when i'm in a
comedy club or a theater i'm looking out
in the audience and i'm going all of
these people have that weight they have
more than that they have kids they have
you know
jobs they have
uh the family members they support they
have a lot lots of weight so to
understand that and to relate to that
for me i think there's a value to it but
i also agree with you
and completely understand that it slows
you down
houses are they slow you down families
even though they're amazing and valuable
can have that effect as well and it's
well worth it to be slowed certain times
slowing down i think is worth it but you
also have to be honest with yourself
that the slowing down is often
artificial like if you're it's in your
mind not to be stoic first for a second
but yeah like
there's no reason you can't sell the
house well absolutely some of it is you
want to make sure you get a house you
can actually afford yes all those kinds
of things but and but even still
people talk about like fu money
and they they use the lack of money or
insufficient amount of money as an
excuse to stay in the job they don't
like stay in the life they don't like
stay in the marriage they don't like
stay in a house they don't like when in
reality you could i think it's an excuse
like most people can take the bold
action it's it's a huge risk but take a
leap into the unknown get rid of the
house
and go pursue a job that you actually
love and then everything else yeah will
just uh
everything do you think everybody loves
something
so this is see this is a
fundamental disagreement that we have
they have the capacity to discover
something they love yes
well that's a different thing so if you
think that there's nothing in this world
you love outside of chemical depression
so if you
if you if there's just the chemistry
that makes you incapable of seeing some
aspect of beauty in the world i think
everybody could discover it and it's a
little
flame that's in everybody that you just
uh
haven't ever met stupid people
i think
part of when i speak to you i speak to a
guy
who's because he's very smart has had
the privilege of speaking to some very
very intelligent people but have you
ever spoken to someone who was not that
smart and i don't mean a bad person
i don't mean a malevolent human being in
any way i mean someone who's not complex
they're a simple yeah person i love so
let me just make clear
that
i don't like the quote-unquote
intelligent people or the elite people
or the rich people i like simple people
simple people people i that's my see
myself as a you say
but you're not but this is when this is
what i'm gonna this is the you've got a
robot on your floor you interviewed the
richest man in the world yesterday this
is when we have to stop you're wearing a
suit it's it's it's 12. i mean rogan
thinks he's a simple man too he owns the
colorado river can we stop
this is when as a comedian i have to
point out how insane this sounds to
everyone you're a brilliant guy you give
lectures at mit you're just not a simple
person i was in bucky's yesterday you
know what bucky's is it's a walmart
competitor
and and bucky is a beaver and and and
it's a big walmart and people go into it
and they buy everything they need and
they have bucky's nuggets and they're
like corn pops the cereal they're not
good for you they're like potato chips
essentially they're like you know this
highly processed sugar food and they're
so popular people go to buckies and they
buy the nuggets and they eat the bucky's
nuggets on their couch yeah don't you
understand that those people
fundamentally have some differences with
you
no i mean okay i just don't think so i
think they
are more like they they appreciate life
more actually than the the may be true
the people who are in this rat race of
like
trying so the quote-unquote smart people
or the people who are climbing some kind
of
uh yes treat like careers said that some
of those people do what you love they
might say i'm doing what i love i love
the bucky's nuggets yeah and i love my
couch first of all that yes
if they
well okay so i wanted to be a
psychiatrist when i was growing up so i
would have to have
like several months worth of sessions
with them to discuss is it truly what
they i think on session two
you would realize that you're kind of
going up against a brick wall no i don't
know not everybody is meant to live this
fully
um
you know like examined life many people
are quite happy
it doesn't have to be examined you don't
have to be you don't have to read
philosophical literature it can just be
honest with yourself like self-reflect
yes in a simple way about what the hell
do you love about life well that's
that's fair and i'm with you on that
yeah i'm with you on that what i think
is what we've done as a society in my
estimation this is one of our
fundamental disagreements we agree on
many things
um you mean you and i i think we agree
on a lot yes but then there's things we
disagree on like uh such as well i think
love
no love is important and essential i
have to talk to you about relationships
we'll do we'll do that in a second but
one of the things where me and you have
a a disagreement is
this very vague and general advice that
we give to people we tell them your life
is not
valid or meaningful unless you have this
dream
that you or this deep love
of something that you have to pursue
and you have to be on this journey
and to me
i know people that derive a lot of
happiness from the greatest
uh simplicities
in their life um whether that might be
uh you know and i'm not saying family is
simple but it might be just having a
family it might be
just being sober
it might be just having enough money to
pay the rent so to me
to tell everybody that
there's a um that they have to love
something
in a way
that motivates them or inspires them
to chase it or follow it
i i think it's a very
it's a very it's incomplete yeah as
advice yeah maybe uh like if there's a
goal that you have to reach for you have
to improve like new year's resolution
style goals sure yeah no i um
i i was like you know these great guys
these david goggins and all these people
are running backwards on the mountain
yes totally get it right i mean that's
great
who is that for like i know it's for
people
like
the the people that run up the hill
are gonna run up the hill
the people that aren't gonna run up the
hill aren't
now sometimes the people that aren't
running up the hill will decide to run
up the hill for me the positive aspect
of david goggins is it wakes you up to
consider
do i want to be a david goggins in this
world or do i want to be something else
like it just it just like shakes you up
like looking at weirdness
like that's a good point like just
looking at something that's completely
out of the ordinary right i mean you
could just look at any kind of weird
video i suppose of a human being doing
anything weird and then it reminds you
wait a minute so people can are capable
of this
so maybe i'm capable of a lot of stuff
what am i actually interested in i was
just having a conversation with somebody
um
and an older woman i've been practicing
russian i've been speaking in russian
with
with uh
folks what's interesting about you
is they hired you at the fsb without
even speaking russian yeah they just let
you yeah that's odd they just said
you'll figure it out yeah yeah they have
a whole
program yeah to get you up to speed fair
enough so i was talking to her and she
said the thing that brings her happiness
is uh
like
this is gonna sound a little bit strange
but so making dinner for her family
putting everybody to bed just three kids
like her husband uh is like waiting for
her in bed or he might be already
sleeping and just sitting there at the
kitchen table
oh also making a breakfast and lunch for
the next day for the kids and just
everything is done
everything is clean everything is
perfect and she's just sitting at the
kitchen table and realizing this is
happiness right and that to me was like
yeah that's another way of happiness and
i i'm the same way to me like
i mean
one form of happiness is just being
pretty good
at whatever i take on so like uh i don't
know organizing any kind of stuff i love
organizing right you couldn't tell it by
this place but like i have an ocd nature
and it makes me feel good
to um to organize stuff like
spreadsheets or data and all those kinds
of things right i could you know people
talk [ __ ] about uh desk you know uh
office work but i would love that i
would love to be an excel person right
organize or you know what like
somebody's assistant
where i like schedule stuff i love
scheduling things you like that yeah i
love it i would uh yeah you were talking
about love earlier yeah and you were
saying it's uh
what what are your thoughts on that as a
organizing principle of
people's lives
and when you see people in relationships
it's very interesting to me i know
people that i think are genuinely in
love like i think ben and his wife are
genuinely in love but i also see other
relationships
that are business arrangements
and they're also successful
truly
so
yeah so that's very interesting yeah
partnerships that's right that's
different from love so
a lot so broadly first of all love to me
is much bigger than romantic love of
course so to put friendship like ever
since i was young
i was at a longing for other human
beings and that connection you have you
you mentioned like uh
sort of uh you know happiness is is
contrasted to the
the suffering or whatever the hardship
that people are going through and that's
kind of your job put yourself in a place
of hardship so you can make people happy
but i i always saw that there's just uh
unfairness and cruelty and all that kind
of stuff in the world and you could just
huddle like penguins together
uh amidst that and that's what
friendship is but aside from humans also
there's just
like
it's sitting at the kitchen table or
like looking out at a tree in nature and
just appreciating to be alive that to me
is love like that connection yes to just
[ __ ] it's good to be alive that feeling
that yeah but romantic love i just have
seen um
just over and over and over again
hanging out with uh rogan and david
goggins in vegas just uh hanging out
with their wives
and seeing like
holy [ __ ] so much of their success has
to do with
with these people and their relationship
that's a huge component and so like i've
interacted with a lot of successful
people where i don't think it's an
accident where there's this belief in
each other excitement for each other and
it's like you also realize that
what the hell are you doing in this
force to your point like what are we
trying to teach people i think
i think success
is is tastes the best
feels the best when you get to share
with people you love yes and that's 100
and that's you know so to me that seems
to be
essential for a happy life is having a
like a inner circle a small collection
of people they just love getting excited
about [ __ ] together with that is
absolutely true and sometimes
they're you know the opposite sex or the
same sex whatever they are then you have
sex with them yes for many years right
and let me ask you an interesting
question that's how that works in your
estimation i look at
jeffrey and gislane and i say they were
in love
that was a a very deep and powerful love
i see the same i i look at you and ben
the same way absolutely yeah he's the
what i mean about that right is you have
this
from the outside world this is a very
interesting conversation right
because everything you just said is
beautiful and true
but let's look at the other side of that
so to us
you have jeffrey anders lane they're
having this amazing love affair they
genuinely deeply love each other do you
think so by the way it seems so okay
right i mean the way they look at each
other
i mean they they really truly seemed
to to love and trust each other yeah
right they built this empire
and
nothing bonds you like doing evil on the
world true
so my question is
is that valid
the love that they have for each other
because it does check a lot of the boxes
of what you talked about where it's like
huddling together
um you know it's us against the world
yeah
is that a valid love yeah it is it is
but it can blind you to such to to where
you can do evil like the harm you're
doing to others like love of nation is
something i also have
right i which nation
that's funny you should ask no of course
man i'm i'm i'm american through through
which is what i would say on a podcast
that's going to be televised i live in
austin texas nothing more american than
that exactly it's it's it really sells i
believe
um i you're shooting guns now i'm gonna
start wearing a cowboy hat just make
people
believe and uh can we edit out the part
where i said we're i talk russian
because that's gonna be uh that's not
gonna fit the brand of what i'm trying
to sell here
no uh
you know you grow up in the soviet union
where the idea i grew up in the soviet
union where the idea of love of country
was really powerful and so much of it is
propaganda but there was a you know
literally the national anthem said
ironically enough were the greatest
country on earth indestructible it is
the greatest the soviet anthem is the
greatest anthem ever written i played in
the car with pen it is the most powerful
you want to talk about musical yeah
prowess i mean it's amazing and i don't
know you should look at the lyrics
because they say we're indestructible
there's a
you know the american national anthem
is kind of polite yes it's proud it's
beautiful yeah the soviet national
anthem is like we're the baddest
[ __ ] on this planet right you
will never destroy us of course it
collapsed yeah so there you go that they
changed it quickly they changed the
national anthem after that but so that's
a love of country
hitler is an example of somebody that
very effectively sold the love of
country right so love
doesn't necessarily create good in the
world right it's this is more kind of um
because love is a very powerful force a
blinding force yeah